two three hours how long did you guys do
distance for
uh
probably
[Music]
a year two years
okay yeah it wasn't too long i hated
distance it was not
and then we've lived together for
maybe five years
something like that
oh wow five years yeah so you guys moved
in together when you were
probably
19 or 20.
would you like recommend that like would
you do that again or would you get
married before you lived with someone
else
um
no i wouldn't you wouldn't get you
wouldn't do it again i wouldn't get
married first okay you need to live with
someone if we can marry them oh i
disagree
i like i don't want to live with anyone
until i married get married
but then
[Music]
living with someone you don't know what
their habits are like having someone
over for a weekend or a week is
completely different to living with them
for five years 100 years
for life i just feel like okay this is
my opinion okay and i think it's the
right one you're entitled to it
so i feel like what else are you gonna
learn about someone like i think most of
my friends i can tell if they're messy
or clean or whatever
and i feel like people
avoid marriage because they're afraid of
like finding something out there being
like some dark skeleton or things
changing or whatever
but
i don't know i'd rather just like
try it give it my best shot
then like
you know spend my life like afraid that
something's gonna come out or we won't
live together like you can figure that
stuff out
then i guess it comes back to is what is
marriage what's the difference of you
living with someone
before and after marriage well i think
marriage is more like conducive to
families
like i would i wouldn't want to have a
kid outside of like i feel like marriage
like i was always happy my parents were
married i think that was good for me as
a kid
yeah yeah yeah with all my family
apart from yeah just two relationships
now that i've broken down i've been
divorced now in my family but
everyone else is married and fine with
their families but
i don't know me and my ex we never saw
marriage as a thing yeah
we saw it as
okay do the paperwork for all the legal
matters and stuff like that
like
obviously i know a woman wants her big
day and all that stuff yeah for me
i'm an introvert i don't want all that
attention but you can do it at like a
court house you know he doesn't have a
big like
but
yeah but if i find the right person and
yeah she wants to have the big day i'll
do that for her yeah
it seems like britain isn't as like i've
heard that a lot in britain
okay the
like what's the difference between
living with someone and getting married
like that that seems to be very common
here
have you seen love is blind
on netflix i saw see the first season i
haven't seen the second
yeah i vaguely remember the first season
that's very
oh my god i would do that that sounds
like so much fun
you would do it oh yeah
someone else who i spoke about it to
yesterday and she was like she has no
understanding of how people can do that
like how can you
decide to marry someone just through
obviously they talk to each other
probably a lot more than we see on the
show but still only through maybe 10 15
20 hours of talking through them
to them through a wall
how can they decide that
you want to marry that person
i don't know i don't think dating longer
decreases the risk of divorce i actually
have
i don't want to quote these because i'm
afraid like it's been a while since i've
looked at them but i went to catholic
school and so they would always have
like chastity speakers come in
and um one of the
they would always quote a statistic that
said that people that didn't live
together before they were married tend
to be married longer
yeah yeah i'll get what you mean yeah
and like i just feel like
at some point like there's going to be
some risk
like no matter how long you date a
person there's always going to be risk
you know
no i'm not going to lie reality tv maybe
not
maybe that that probably isn't the best
way to do it
plus when are those statistics from
they're probably from
10 15 years ago yeah no that's again
yeah yeah yeah i agree that's why
different works what it was 50 years ago
it's even a different work to what it
was 10 years ago now
yeah you don't change the world actually
the development of birth control
because before that like people had to
get married so much younger like how
many grandparents got married because
the grandma was like knocked up
yeah i guess so but then there's been a
lot in the news
if you had seen it in the uk
of
people in like the 60s when they did get
pregnant out of wedding out of marriage
they had to give up their child
really i've never heard of that there's
been a lot of
like
women who are now like 40 only just
meeting their actual biological mother
really and it was all like a government
thing
i've never heard of that that's in the
uk yeah yeah and now there's some sort
of investigation into it and apology
going to all those 60 year old ladies
who had to give up their child
it's a bit late for that but
yeah yeah oh my god that is insane
i you know i had my mom gave up a kid
for adoption actually
really yeah i met him when i was 22. i
found out he existed is he older
yeah yeah my dad knocked up my mom when
she was 17. and they got married five
years later but
yeah when they were 22 they told me i
had a brother named greg
and i was like what kind of name is greg
no offense greg if you're watching this
respectfully
but yeah i guess they were telling the
truth and they gave
up him for adoption and he's like fine
and stuff he grew up to be like a
software sales software engineer
but it was crazy the similarities are
actually like nuts really yeah
he like walks like us
did your grandparents know about that
yeah they did okay they wanted her to
keep it they wanted to keep it yeah they
wanted my mom to keep him wow okay they
were like very against it my mom
but yeah my mom
just didn't feel like she was ready she
was too young
sensible choice then yeah i know
but
interesting
i feel like i keep getting off topic i
do that yeah i'm not already going
through the whole face
well because i thought you'd have like a
strong opinion one way or the other with
the whole face
do you think that anything is just sorry
because of the whole
way society is sexualized in every way
now that
it seems girl guys have just got like
lad banner go out there pull girls
and then
girls watching all this reality tv are
like oh yeah i gotta find a guy and
sleep with him stuff like that i feel
when you do get out of relationship
like mine where there's not been that
sexual relationship for the last
couple of months
maybe it's something that you're looking
for and you're just like yeah get me
anything yeah yeah
but
i wouldn't say it's necessary yeah
is a need of some people yeah
do you think that's good for society or
bad for society that it's so sexualized
now because some some people have talked
to think it's like a good thing
and others think it's the worst thing
ever
um
i'd say i'm neutral about it like
at the end of the day what has made it's
marketing that's made everything sexual
and
if that makes money and boosts economy
and makes people rich
then it's good
would you
actually got a question would you date a
girl with an only fans
but she's making enough money to like
depends on the content really how
no it's it's it's sexual content but but
she's making millions
i'd get in on it
you'd get in on it yeah
be the special guest in the content
really
so you would you would would you marry a
girl
that day
yeah mother of your kids
it would definitely have to be a
conversation
i'd have to be a converse so maybe you'd
consider it
it would be a conversation
i think that is not i don't know what
way it would go
hold on i'm gonna check the chat really
quick
also if you send a 50 super chat
i don't drink but i'll take a shot
um okay let me read see if anyone's put
questions
in the chat
um
[Music]
you need
what do you think of this comment you
need to hook up with 60 girls as a man
to be able to understand them and have
standards
i'd say from an eight-year relationship
i've certainly got the understanding of
females
i want to ask you questions
what do you mean by that
like what do you understand about
females recently
just how they deal with
i life know every female is different
and like
i think you really do have to go for a
big talking phase to get to know someone
first
[Music]
to know if you're compatible
and like what your values are
and if you if so if it's actually
something that can work in the future
because
opposites don't always attract
and within a relationship it's probably
never really going to attract
so what does that have to do with like
females
what about them
no you said you understand like female
nature now or like you understand more
about females like what have you learned
what have i done